mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
maler und malerinnen maler musiker und
musikerinnen machen musik sind kreativ
doch warum
was treibt sie an warum ich kreativ bin
es bewahrt mich davor verrückt zu werden
wir fragen heute welches geheimnis
steckt hinter kreativen schaffen
beschreibt heidi happy zb ihre betörende
songs ein kulturplatz aus dem reich der
kreativität
[Musik]
warum
ja was wäre das leben ohne musik ohne
jene menschen die sie komponieren und
spielen
herzlich willkommen bei kulturplatz wir
fragen heute danach wo die kunst egal
welcher sparte überhaupt herkommt wo
herziehen kreative ihre urkraft wann
werden sie von der muse geküsst und
warum überhaupt sind menschen kreativ
beispielsweise die luzerner musikerin
heidi happy
sie gehört zu den eigenwilligsten
musikerinnen der schweizer szene seit
mehr als zehn jahren schon existiert die
kunstfigur heidi happy hinter der sich
die luzernerin priska zemp verbirgt
die musik der multi instrumentalistin
ist über die jahre facettenreicher und
tiefgründiger geworden
[Musik]
die einflüsse ihrer musik reichen von
folk bis hin zu klassik
ihre musikalische begabung kommt nicht
von ungefähr
brisk us mutter eine sopranistin brachte
ihr bereits mit sechs jahren das
klavierspielen bei ihr debütalbum back
together zeichnete sie in der nähe von
amsterdam auf wo sie studierte auch in
den folgenden jahren zog es sie immer
wieder in die stadt mit den vielen
brachten
um der zunehmenden bekanntheit zu
entfliehen
[Musik]
sie arbeitete schon mit schweizer musik
größen wie jan o
[Musik]
diese heraus
mit stephan eicher mit dem sie das erste
mal in mundart sind
diese sind
für diesen
diese weise
[Musik]
wie viele instrumente sie spielt weil
sie vielleicht selbst gar nicht klavier
cello gitarre vibraphon mandoline
melodica als multitalent komponiert sie
viel musik und für ihr album hiding with
the wolves auch für ein ganzes orchester
und im moment entsteht ein neues album
[Musik]
wie gesagt mir jetzt du trotz die stadt
verbracht da geht es über die
grundstücke heidi happy was ein ticket
für zwei richtungen an heidi happy
schaffte zum super sogar so persönliche
text geschrieben dass ich niemals
übertrieben und beruflich nicht genau
stimmt und es ist einfach teil die
hartwig sie will als priester seien
praktisch wie das problem kann idee
lacht sie und mittlerweile bin ich wenn
ich auf tour bin ich heidi und sagen wir
also unter stelle mich also vor und
priska wenig der heime nach den tätern
und ohne kurze ganzen liter laden oder
illustriere zum beispiel warum bist du
so sehr geliebt sondern mich beschäftigt
und sich mini art das verarbeiten wir
uns alle und ich hatte zwar schade und
ich hatte überreden aber es ist für mich
wieder mal etwas anders wenn ich was
mache ich dafür bessern wir eine
ironische note trainer irgendwie so zu
verpacken dass ist nicht so tragisch
nehmen und melodie ist in die mikrofone
was macht ja genau also am see wie die
stars machen viel verschlafen oder
sofort bis zehn und der us-komiker
schlafmohn weiße löwen und gar nicht
zurück und nehmen es allen teams
oder wenn der nächste highlight kommt
die machen gerade jetzt versorgen
keine einfache frage warum bist du
kreativ der filmemacher hermann vaske
hat sie weltweit prominenten
künstlerinnen und künstlern gestellt
entstanden ist ein projekt das tief nach
den motiven schrift
über 30 jahre lang war er unterwegs
hermann vaske regisseur und
forschungsreisender in sachen
kreativität immer auf der suche nach dem
heiligen gral des kreativen schaffens
nach der motivation der künstlerinnen
und künstler für ihre kreativen
expedition immer mit der einen frage
warum sind sie kreativ mai laden wurde
zu einer endlosen serie von flüchtigen
treffen und kurzen gespräch alles begann
in london in den 1980 er wo hermann
vaske studierte und bei der renommierten
werbeagentur saatchi & saatchi arbeitete
westdeutschen grauen nach kriegsszenario
herauskatapultiert und plötzlich hat man
gemerkt da kann man sachen in fragen die
man sich nicht traute zu fragen es hat
einen richtig raus gelüftet und dann kam
diese frage why you create und diese
frage hatte endlos und jedem und jeder
gestellt david lynch angelina jolie
christoph schlingensief in dem stephen
hawkins marina abramovic den dalai lama
david bowie und jan o
haben wir jemanden vergessen ach ja jörg
wiebking vivienne westwood und nelson
mandela und vielen vielen vielen mehr
[Musik]
es ist ein tauchen ein quasi auf die
topografie des ozeans der kreativität
wenn man neue sachen entdeckt in vazquez
film spielt zu aller erst die familiäre
umgebung eine große rolle
der zauber der kindheit ich blieb im
gleichen metier wie meine eltern meine
mutter ingrid bergman war schauspielerin
mein vater roberto rossellini regisseur
am anfang sind wir alle kreativ bauen
sandburgen verkaufen limonade und dann
greifen die praktischen dinge des lebens
ein
und nicht jeder bleibt kreativ wie
picasso sagte jedes kind ist ein
künstler
das problem ist nur ein künstler zu
bleiben während man älter wird
hermann vaske legt verschiedene
motivation schickten frei und findet die
individuellen beweggründe für
kreativität auch in den blockaden in den
feinden der kreativität den killer in
der angst
angst kann durchaus ein treiber seien ja
weil oft sind die faktoren die die die
kreativität bedrohen genau die diese
antreiben
warum ich kreativ bewahrt mich dafür
verrückt zu werden
[Musik]
unsere größte angst im leben ist die
angst vor dem tod
alle haben angst davor wir reden nicht
darüber oder versuchen sie sogar zu
verleugnen
ich bin kreativ weil ich sex liebe
sexualität die treibende kraft für ihre
kreativität
es ist ein werkzeug in jedem kreativen
bereich gibt es bestimmte vokabular mit
denen man arbeitet und sexualität ist
eines davon
eine kreative seite funktioniert extrem
gut und ist extrem reichhaltig und sie
ist nicht in einer balance mit dem rest
meines lebens ein anderes leben leidet
sehr unter meiner vielseitigen
kreativität freundschaften leiden
beziehungen leiden die beziehung zu
meiner familie leidet
auf seiner reise trifft hermann vaske
immer wieder auf künstlerinnen und
künstler für die kreativität wie ein
unentrinnbaren schicksal zu sein scheint
genauso wie was gesuche nach ihren
motiven
[Musik]
das ganze abenteuer schien außer
kontrolle zu geraten aber ich konnte
nicht mehr aufhören
das ist einfach eine eine ewige reise zu
neuen zielen
und wenn sie ein ziel haben wenn sie
wenn sie irgendwo hin wollen in der
kreativen arbeit dann ist das ein
wahnsinniger beschleuniger
deshalb führte hermann vaske nicht nur
interviews er ließ die menschen die er
befragte auch etwas zeichnen ein bild
machen
eine skizze einen satz schreiben
[Musik]
daraus entstand 2018 ein buch und eine
ausstellung mit über 300 exponaten
visuelle antworten und kommentare auf
die frage why you create ich habe mich
geschnitten im gesicht und dieses blut
habe ich auf ein blatt papier gestrichen
[Musik]
es liegt mir im blut ich wache auf und
werde von etwas angetrieben
und das bringt mich dazu kreativ zu sein
[Musik]
hermann vaske reise zeigt wie
verschieden die motive sind was sie
verbindet ist etwas metaphysisches eine
sehnsucht etwas tun zu müssen zu
verändern
rebellisch zu sein und kreativität als
etwas zu entdecken was man einfach
intuitiv lebt als lebensform übrigens
hermann was neues projekt heißt while
you're not creative
[Musik]
die zehn musiker doch reine zum schaffen
meistens und der halt alle instrumente
also für mich ist dieses paradies will
seinem ruhm ist alles da was ich brauche
die verbrauchten wir spezielle umgebung
für die günstige dinka china und ewig
währt die schöpferisch schaffen oder ist
das bewusst
also daran ist glücklich dass ich bis h
obwohl sich neutral strate familie also
ideale ries forderte aber ich schaue
mich zurückziehen ort unterwegs war
monatelang schaffen und das ist schon
nochmal besonders also daran ist schon
einmal andere sprache und dann habe ich
im kopf und schauen was passiert ja also
wir haben eben wie eine idee aufgelaufen
hellen die ich als normal ruhrgebietes
kürzungen ist
und rooney ich bin ja so sitzt da und
mach' ich völlig anderes licht besser
ist es noch schlechter
das probieren
[Musik]
20 mal drüber stehen
[Gelächter]
was macht dir aber also jetzt reicht's
muss ich meine idee war schuf und was
jetzt passiert etwas größeres wäre also
mir aber jetzt ist selbst wenn ich die
wahrheit ja schon ziemlich abgebrochen
frings nicht ehrlich ja aber das gefühl
die die sache für die ich am wichtigsten
sind musikalisch wo es für durchaus in
sachen fisch das umtrieben emotional und
dann mich auf jeden fall sogar sehr
lange nicht was nur traurige songs
geschrieben wir sehen wir die emotionen
zu sehen wird mehr reden wie so fest
sind wie viel kann ich muss dir los
werde vielmehr sehen wir im horizont
tanzen oder so wahnsinnig viel in dieses
muster wiederholt mit was du los man
brauche also meistens vorne aber mit der
gitarre
also wenn ich nur mal als beispiel ein
fehler vor
[Musik]
ja klar kreatives schaffen ist der motor
viele veränderungen aber innovation und
fortschritt verdanken wir nicht nur
einsame genies sondern auch den dialog
dem prozesshaften dahinter und davon
erzählt stefan kleins neues buch wie wir
die welt verändern
albert einstein seine
relativitätstheorie ein geniestreich der
physik geschichte
marie curie entdeckerin der
radioaktivität pionierin der
röntgentechnik steve jobs erfinder des
smartphones touch statt tasten es geht
nicht mehr ohne
zündende ideen große genies verändern
die welt
diese populäre these erklärt
wissenschaftsautor stefan klein in
seinem buch kurzerhand zum mythos weil
keines der menschen die wir so alice
loben für sich alleine gedacht hat
natürlich gibt es menschen die mehr
einflussreiche beiträge zu unserer
kultur geleistet haben als andere aber
keiner wirklich keiner dieser menschen
hat für sich alleine gearbeitet die
waren alle eingebunden in eine
zusammenarbeit mit mitstreitern mit
menschen die mit ihnen gedacht haben und
über die wird nicht geredet
die forschung gibt klein recht einsteins
hirn wird nach dessen tod untersucht
es stellt sich als gewöhnlich heraus bis
heute schreibt kleine fehler ein
nachweis dafür dass geniale ideen
biologischen ursprungs sind
der mini kult ist nicht nur falsch und
unrealistisch ich finde ihn auch
gefährlich er ist gefährlich deswegen
weil wir da glauben die kreativen
fähigkeiten seien etwas was einige
wenige haben und alle anderen nicht
und diesen aberglauben hat die
neuropsychologie also die hirnforschung
in den letzten jahren
gründlich widerlegt belegt dagegen ist
menschliche kreativität entwickelt sich
exponentiell die gattung homo braucht
anfangs ihre zeit neues zu schöpfen vom
einseitig behauenen steinwerkzeug bis
zum viel effizienteren zweiseitigen
vergehen mehr als eine million jahre ab
dem späten mittelalter zündet die
menschheit den kreativität turbo
zwischen gutenbergs buchdruck und dem
ersten smartphone liegen noch gut 550
jahre
heute arbeiten maschinen dank
künstlicher intelligenz schneller und
präziser als der mensch verdrängen
maschinen demnächst die menschliche
kreativität
das können maschinen nicht weil
maschinen keine eigenen ziele verfolgen
können das sind brave soldaten also die
tun das was man ihnen befohlen hat ich
glaube dass wir viele ideen künftig
zusammen mit maschinen entwickeln werden
aber sie können unsere intelligente
nicht ersetzen
kreativität ist heute ein ökonomischer
treiber kreative cluster wie das
gewerbehaus nerd in zürich-oerlikon
werten städte neu auf kathrin robert hat
über die wertschöpfung der
kreativwirtschaft ihre doktorarbeit
verfasst
in der schweiz arbeiten fast eine halbe
million menschen in kreativen berufen
viele von ihnen selbstständig häufig
projektbezogen grenzen zwischen arbeit
und freizeit zerfließen die neue schöne
kreativ welt wird neue risiken sicher
wir ein anderer ort wo prekarisierung
was man das frieren erkannt hat oder
sind manche so schlecht muss billiger
hand oder irgendwie schon vor vier
chancen kann wer sich eine schlacht der
milieu aufgewachsen sind
das wissen sie ob es mache wenig sinn
geht und könnten die risiken die ohren
und anteilig sehr schlechte ab
sicherlich sehr schwankende auftrag und
im kommen
und sin todestages belastet die
menschheit verändert die welt weil sie
dazu fähig ist
und wenn sie sich damit wieder einmal in
eine krise manövriert ist schwan
kreativität mehr gefragt denn je
dass die menschheit fähig war innerhalb
von acht monaten einen impfstoff für
eine globale pandemie zu entwickeln ich
finde dass ich finde das fantastisch und
ich glaube dass es viele probleme gibt
die keinen aufschub dulden kommende
probleme und aufgaben ja kein genie der
welt alleine lösen kann
[Musik]
zurück in heidi happy es kreativ labor
dem musikzimmer
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich habe die krise überhaupt
dazu gehören zusätzlich natürlich wenn
sie durch mich zu denen die sagen zeigen
die musikklassen zeigen ja gut da was
gedreht wurden wie kranke kind und
dancemusik kosten trägt das nexgen
besser gott wenn sie die musik lasse und
dann selbst ist für mich das größte
wenn ich merke dass eine direkte wirkung
auf größten person ich war immer gleich
wie viel mittel politisch sie zum
beispiel in der musik hatte landete
verendet willig sind sowie hilfreich
wenn ich rede mir immer eine größere und
findet seit den attacken über muss
betrifft und recht also wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie rallye zu bedenken dass ich
mir so wichtig dass es jeden wackler
wird und da fand ich so doof wenn ich
das nicht wird nütze das ist das
öffentlich sagen wenn ich das gefühl hat
die vielleicht sogar anrufe nur schon
trotz danke abstimmen oder shop ist also
da bin ich froh dass ich die
ordnungspolizei
[Musik]
nun
sie ist klagt ziehen
ist das so
[Musik]
das meinte sie ich liebe kreative
zerstörer immer durch schwierig sie so
oft genannt wird ist dass wir nicht
genau wie sonne und nächste woche widmen
wir uns einer ganz besonderen
menschlichen beziehung nämlich jene von
vätern und töchtern und hier geht es
weiter mit der zweiten staffel des
steirischen dramas die wege des herrn
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
street los
[Musik]